50 000 Witcher fans can't be wrong or
can they here's how some of the show's
most loyal Watchers are trying to keep
the dream of a Henry cavill-led Witcher
alive fans of Netflix's The Witcher are
still reeling from the recent news that
Cavill will no longer be donning his
iconic white wig after season three
enjoy your last walk across the matter
and through the Mist kavel has
officially laid down his swords as
geralt of Rivia and will instead be
picking up that iconic red cape once
again some have speculated that the
actor's departure from the Netflix
series was due to incompatible work
schedules without a doubt fighting crime
and the forces of evil as Superman is an
intensive and time-consuming position to
be in not to mention that in all
likelihood being part of the DC Universe
pays better than acting on The Witcher
however many fans aren't too happy that
Cavill won't be returning to the role
and will be replaced by Australian actor
and brother to Thor Liam Hemsworth out
of all this discontentment a change.org
petition emerged similar to what
happened after game of their own season
8 aired the petition titled Netflix you
must keep Henry Cavill as The Witcher
and replace the writers instead has
blown up and as of the making of this
video it has reached nearly 50 000
signatures Steph ma the creator of the
petition wrote in part let us show them
in pure numbers that none of us Witcher
fans will stand with them and will
abandon the show and potentially our
subscriptions after The Witcher season 3
is concluded unfortunately this puts
Liam Hemsworth who can't be blamed for
the recasting in an unfavorable position
on an Instagram post the Australian
actor acknowledged that Cavill handed
him the Reigns of the series beloved
protagonist and while some commenters
showed their support many others
expressed their displeasure one of the
top comments with over 5000 likes reads
no stop you can't replace Henry Witcher
fans have been quite vocal about their
opposition to the major change all over
the internet on Reddit there are
multiple threads about the recasting one
user wrote well there goes the single
redeeming factor of the show this got
several replies including I actually
really like Joey Beatty The Bard song is
cool and his character is slowly
developing rather nicely but yeah other
than that you're totally right a drink
I'm gonna drink I am not having this
conversation unless I'm drinking indeed
one shouldn't discredit the other actors
who have also fully dedicated themselves
to the series like Beatty and your
chalotra and Freya Allen however
together they don't seem to be enough to
relieve fans doubts regarding the future
of the series during his three seasons
on The Witcher Henry Cavill seemed born
to play girl to Rivia this was in great
part thanks to the incredible passion
Cavill nurtured for the fantasy
franchise first as a fan of the video
games and later as a fan of Andrei
zapovsky's novels in an interview with
Graham Norton caval was asked whether he
knew more than anyone else on set ever
humble Cavill denied knowing more than
anyone else and just called himself a
big fan Norton then asked whether he
corrected others on set to which kavel
replied that he doesn't adding I'm I am
effusive about getting the uh being
being loyal to the source material let's
put it that way those are the operative
words loyal to the source material it
has somewhat become common knowledge
that even those who haven't read the
books that the Netflix show especially
after the first season strayed
fromkovsky's original story although
Cavill has never outright said it his
comments to Norton suggest that he might
not have been content with the direction
the series to Take It ultimately leading
to him stepping down as the Monster
Hunter
foreign